[Music]
hey y'all
look at the weird sunlight in here yeah
we're just bouncing off the floor what
the [ __ ] is like all over here that [ __ ]
looks sexy it looks like i'm
having sex with some kind of orb
[Laughter]
i was gonna say he's gonna start
thrusting now yeah yeah
that's a weird [ __ ] oh my god the show
just came on and he's already thrusting
it over he's doing [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] so
i got shorts on too yeah
so
we uh this this we saw we've been on
this [ __ ] um charles bronson kick
because they're showing free ones on you
on youtube yeah this is on 2b for free
too yeah they're worth seeing they're
good they got good ones up there they
got one i think it's called the the
assassination i think is the other one
that they just put up i have to check it
again it's either the assassin or
assassination
um so this one came up mr majestic it's
good um
i wouldn't say it's quite as good as
as uh the the mechanic
but they're very different kind of
movies the mechanic is kind of weird and
dark this one not so much it's kind of
just like a uh
it's kind of a neo-western
and uh i can
charlie plays i'm gonna call him charlie
me and charlie we're telling you me and
charlotte
charlie charlie plays basically ramble a
dude that was decorated you find out
later you know how's this dude doing all
this badass [ __ ] he's just a watermelon
farmer it turns out he's like a vietnam
war veteran and escaped captivity and
did a bunch of [ __ ]
um
and it's also a little bit like john
wick he's just trying to get the damn
watermelon just trying to pick my melons
you guys god damn it starts off
he's driving around in his truck
and uh he sees a bunch of migrant
workers i'm presuming they're from
mexico or they're from somewhere south
of the border
and they're they're at the gas station
trying to try to use the restroom one of
them is this uh hot looking uh mexican
chick nancy i think yeah she's probably
about 40 uh but she looks a lot younger
and the the gas
station attendant won't let him in to
use the restroom and and bronson's like
what the [ __ ] why don't you just let him
in he goes man
every time they go in there and make a
mess i don't know these people are that
kind of [ __ ] you know they just go in
there the whole family goes in and they
take showers and blah blah blah i take
showers
you know
and this is my gas station i don't want
to clean it up so bronson [ __ ] he
puts up with it for a few minutes and
then he goes what the [ __ ] do you care
it's not your gas station let him in let
the girl [ __ ] pee
[Laughter]
i mean he didn't say it that'd been
funny if he said that basically with
what he should have said
he had me writing the dialogue
so he roughs the dude up [ __ ] makes
him go in there which kind of the girl
kind of thanks him for it
well uh he gives him a ride in a town
uh
well it gives him right back to where
they were living wasn't it or was it
just
he wanted to show him he needed these
watermelons picked yeah and they were
looking for work because that's what
they did they they picked fruit what's
he doing poop
so he takes him back to his farm and
when he gets there
they got dudes out there picking and
picking uh watermelons already and he
stops wait what the [ __ ] is this like i
just went to get a crew and who the [ __ ]
are you where you picking my watermelon
and they got some dude trying to muscle
his way in and he's just some two-bit
cowboy and [ __ ] old fake 50s looking
cowboy outfit i was like nice
from the [ __ ] halfway house or the
[ __ ] trunk bin or something you know
they're all these wineries because all
these wine
i need professionals you know
professional fruit pickers
and he gets in a big [ __ ] fight and
and and well the two-bit cowboys like
you know what are you doing siding with
these latins man these are white people
i got them out of the damn drunk tank
let them [ __ ] take it they're drunk
ass white people they don't know how to
pick watermelons
he's trying to muscle his way in he's
[ __ ] demanding payment and [ __ ]
and uh [ __ ] goes too far and [ __ ]
[ __ ] charlie beats his ass [ __ ]
hits him in the [ __ ] they pull it
down the nut sack ran it right with the
butt of a shotgun because they pulled a
shotgun on him and [ __ ] charlie takes
a shotgun [ __ ] hits dude in the nuts
with it puts him up and then he gives
the shotgun back [ __ ] gets puts it in
the trunk and get [ __ ] out of here
so he thought it was all cool you know
what i mean
mexicans start [ __ ] picking they're
like all right we gotta we're working
for a good dude so he's out there for
only a couple hours and the cops show up
and they rest his ass because of course
the little whiny cowboy [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] ratted him out he hit my nose
yeah
so he is locked up
and uh he's begging him he says look man
i got to get these [ __ ] watermelons
picked [ __ ]
yeah they'll go right and it's like
that's his whole like that's his year's
crap you know let me out on my own
reconnaissance basically i'll come back
for uh i'll come back for trial and
everything and like if you lock me up
you lock me up but at least i'll get the
watermelons out
and uh
what they end up doing is um
i can't remember exactly how it was well
he goes
he goes into the into the holding cell
and then you deal with him well he goes
into the holding cell what happens and
he gets on the wrong side of this really
uh
gangster with like anger issues yeah
he's an actor too isn't he he's an actor
and a gangster i think wouldn't he no i
think that i think the joke about that
was he
thought that it looked like
somebody that was like on tv okay okay
because then remember after like after
he got uh arrested again or whatever he
was like oh i guess he's a tv yeah you
know what i mean so he gets in a fight
with his badass while he's in [ __ ]
basically the town jail
and turns out this guy's an assassin
and
[ __ ] um they lock him up put him in
the the damn uh
bus to take him to central lockup
and just out of the blue this assassin's
[ __ ]
competition is his team
[ __ ] hijack the truck shoot up a
bunch of cops and try to
get him out of the damn truck to get to
to recapture him before he goes into
central knock-up
and um [ __ ] charlie sees his [ __ ]
he's chained the the the assassin can't
get out of the bus everybody else can
leave but they got the assassin because
he's high risk they got him handcuffed
to the
to the seat to the seat
well charlie sees his [ __ ] chance he
goes [ __ ] it i'm taking off with this
dude
so he steals the prisoner
all right and [ __ ] starts roughing
him up he gets him out in the country
starts roughing him up says walk they
walk to a dam
across the it's his hunting camp yeah
it's in his hunt take him to his hunting
cabin way up in the mountains in
california it's colorado actually is it
colorado does it look like california
no it's colorado they shot it in
california no they shot it in colorado
okay and it's supposed to be close
makeup okay no it's supposed to be in
colorado it's all in colorado really
because it looks like california no it's
colorado all right and okay i'm gonna
let jenny [ __ ] handle that part but
to me it's california i don't care what
what what the movie says i'm looking at
it it looks like no
they shot it in colorado okay it's
colorado okay i'm telling you okay
so anyway
he uh
he uh
eventually calls back the cops
and a bunch of cool [ __ ] happens during
all this time he says look i got this
high value prisoner
i'll give him back to you
if you if you drop the charges on me
you know it's just like a simple assault
charge anyway it wasn't like a big deal
and they cut they wanted to negotiate
but the assassins like it's like look
man i'll give you twenty thousand
dollars if you just let me go
because i'll even call somebody and
[ __ ] they'll come bring the money you
know uh no it didn't work out that way
he kind of betrayed that dude it goes in
this big old thing and finally
finally the the bad guy
escapes doesn't he yeah and and
um charlie gets thrown back into custody
and they were gonna put him in jail but
the cops are like look this dude's
trying to kill you for what you did to
him he wants vengeance so we're gonna
let you go and use you as bait
okay because he's gonna come back to
kill you and when he does we're gonna
we're gonna capture
so he goes back to the farm and he's
trying to get the them
be good to the workers and get them paid
get the damn
watermelons picked
and the assassin comes back with his
team and they [ __ ] up all the damn
watermelons so they [ __ ] run a dude
over while he's taking a piss in the
damn portage potty they [ __ ] beat
everybody up they [ __ ] capture people
oh they do all kinds of bad [ __ ]
cop's nowhere to be seen dudes on his
own so he has to go rambo on his own
throughout the movie to try to
take care of all these gangsters and
protect these uh migrant workers that
he's got
it's good it's real good um
i am glad that uh that charles bronson
called out the cops later on yeah
because he's like [ __ ] you know i
thought this whole thing was you were
gonna like use me for bait and i'm on my
goddamn farm and he's like so this
gangster and this and the original tom
mix cowboy cosplay dude with the big
bulbous forehead yeah they're like all
out there he's like [ __ ] up my [ __ ]
like you know running over one of the
deputies who was in a porta potty like
you know beating up all the workers and
all this other kind of [ __ ]
messing up all my watermelons trying to
rape the girls yeah and then like the
cops like never even show up and i'm
sitting there thinking it's making me
think that i think that the cops wanted
the hitman to like kill charlie first
and then
because they're like hey we killed two
birds with one stone yeah yeah but it it
it ends up in this big uh
[ __ ] showdown and over at the
assassins it was the assassins one of
his houses wasn't it or was it the boss
yes he had a big old house up in the up
in the mountains it's pretty good
now the uh the [ __ ] cowboy guy who
started the whole thing who joins up
with the he joins up with the assassins
to try to help them find charlie
that dude is being played by the guy who
played the crazy biker out of the omega
man the guy who was the medical student
with all the who was taking care of the
kids it's that guy yeah
which this is the only other movie i've
seen him in he does a good job in the
movie and the guy who plays the bad guy
i think that's the same dude who played
the bad guy
from that one movie that had sally
struthers in it when she was like 21
when she was really hot and [ __ ] he
stole her away from that he he uh
he
forgot the name of this movie he used a
gun to [ __ ] hijack a couple
and
the guy was significantly older than
than uh than sally strothers probably
about 20 years and he was a real dick to
her
and he was making making him drive them
around while he was raping raping her in
the back seat over the time she ended up
[ __ ] liking him better than the
husband and then he killed himself that
was just part of it
and then i can't remember i don't
remember the name of that movie they got
to find it it's a sadly struggles movie
well she's a bit part in it really
it's not
it wasn't a steve mcqueen movie
but you guys will recognize him when you
see him i think it's that same guy
mustache curly hair i've seen him before
he looks like uh like geraldo rivera
yeah but except considerably wider yeah
like geraldo's slightly roided and yeah
i was gonna say like a hulked out yeah
bulked out yeah
and [ __ ] mean big belly on him but
you still wouldn't be the kind of dude
you'd [ __ ] with
although gotta say i mean kind of dumb
but he's yeah he's an idiot well i mean
he's an idiot because
he just lets he's just like i don't even
care i want this dude dead yeah that's
his emotions run away with yeah and even
after everybody's like okay this is like
a really stupid idea and you're just
like getting all your own dudes killed
and you're getting you know you're
putting your own life at risk because
the cops are going to catch you and he's
like i don't care i just want that melon
farmer you know what i mean so he's not
he's not real rational is what we're
saying um but yeah so a couple people
have pointed out that this movie was
actually written by the very famous
elmore leonard
uh this was actually he wrote the
novelization of it later but this was
like an original screenplay
uh you know most people know who elmer
leonard is probably his most famous uh
being get shorty uh which was really
good he also did rum punch which they
made into jackie brown
so yeah he's written a [ __ ] ton of stuff
this was directed i thought you would
find this interesting by richard
fleischer who did twenty thousand
leagues embassy fantastic voyage dr
doolittle tora toratora soylent green
yeah cody and the destroyer yeah and red
sonja yeah among other things didn't
want to see red sonja again but man they
want a lot a lot for it on blu-ray zach
said he saw this movie last night what
did he say
he said uh the mechanic yeah okay he
watched the mechanic last night i love
the cinematography it does that dark
moody 70s lighting i love so much and
the shock composition was so
sexy that's what i was talking about
zach saw what i was talking about
they had that gay eye going on the gay
guy
zach is like i know the [ __ ]
i know you saw it zach
and zach there's no way there's no way
that um
charles bronson did not know that that
was the subtext in that movie they just
left it unspoken which i think that was
a good artistic
i think that was a good artistic
statement just
let you figure it out what was going on
between them two yeah
they just left it let it
they let you interpret it for what it
was
which i i think that was
i think it was kind of artistic that way
it was also
market wise it was safer decision
yeah because like i said they absolutely
could not get uh funding for the movie
and a lot of actors didn't want to be in
it if the if it had been explicitly they
got around it yeah but that is
definitely what that movie says
that's definitely what that movie says
so yeah but i mean this one is a lot
different like you said this one's
almost kind of like more like a
neo-western yeah um
but rambo the one thing about it though
is john wick
yeah
i just want to pick my message
and the thing and it's i like it because
it's kind of like it is kind of like
rambo in that way where you know rambo
in the first movie uh before it turned
more into like a cartoon but
he was just kind of like trying to go
about his life you know he's like i
don't want to you know i've been to the
war i have seen all [ __ ] up [ __ ] i
don't want to like [ __ ] deal with it
anymore i just want to have a quiet
existence and then people just kept
[ __ ] with him and [ __ ] with him
and [ __ ] then he finally was like
okay well you got it you asked for it
you unleash the beast
and this was kind of like that too
because honestly they didn't really make
a big deal
of charles bronson's character mr
majestic his first name was vince
although i don't think they ever called
him that he just called him majestic
yeah
um so
i don't even think they brought up the
fact that he had been a pow or that he
was any kind of like badass anything the
cops brought it up yeah no i i what i
was gonna say if you'd let me finish all
this oh okay yeah was that
this is what happens when you just when
you don't let me finish the sentence
what i was going to say was that they
don't bring it up until the about the
halfway point of the movie yeah it was
what i was going to say yeah that made
it better so yeah and so that's what i
like about it so like at the beginning
you're just thinking this is a farmer
yeah how does he do this like how is he
doing all this stuff one thing that kind
of like annoyed me though well it didn't
annoy me but i'm saying the character
annoyed me but he's supposed to
is the the cowboy dude
uh what was his name copis
i think it's uh and he came like in this
ridiculous like outfit that he was
wearing that i'm sure he thought looked
really like my mom made it for me he was
trying to be like a stereotype he's
trying to be a cowboy but yeah but he
was dressed like a dick it looked like a
costume like a costume like your mom
would make you for halloween not quite
that bad not as bad as like joe don
baker in final justice it was a gay
cowboy shirt yeah a little bit that's
like
yeah if you've go if you were if you
were in midnight cowboy yeah yeah and
you went to new york city and like we're
down on this trip like hustling yeah
that's like what you would wear if that
was your stick yeah that's that's your
that's your it was that kind of a booty
selling cowboy outfit so i was kind of
confused at first because you know
charles bronson he goes
he goes and picks up his crew for the
day you know uh and brings them back in
the bus and then there's all these dudes
already working in there and he's like
who the [ __ ] are all these people and
then like the cowboy dude is sitting
there going yeah i already brought you a
career i'm just like who the [ __ ] are
you like what are you even doing just
muscling in yeah and that's the thing
and uh so charles bronson he didn't know
who he was either he just like some
[ __ ] showed up yeah i guess he was
just some well he was hooked in what he
was hooked up with he was some kind of
gangster type of thing he knew who the
other contractors were remember yeah
because he was scaring him off later
i guess he was trying he was trying to
run like a protection around yeah yeah
so he had found out through the other
contractors that there was job that he
was looking for a job and he muscled in
on it
okay
remember because he says i'm looking for
somebody yeah you know so the other
contractors were probably gonna do it
but he muscled those guys out and put
his own dudes in
from behind the scenes yeah because i
thought it had something to do with like
maybe some of the other farmers didn't
like that maybe he paid a little bit
more like the workers or something i
don't really know what was going on but
yeah so this guy just kind of like shows
up and
how weird would that be if you just like
showed up at your farm and like right
some random ass dude is like hey he
showed up with a bunch of bombs yeah
but they were white bombs yeah yeah it
was just
that was his that was his [ __ ]
selling point these are
[Laughter]
you're white you need to give the money
to these white guys right that's what he
was trying to do it didn't work even
though he brought him like your boss he
said from the drunk tank yeah they
weren't dating and even and even charles
bronson said that yeah
he says yeah he's widows i need trained
people you know that know how to do this
yeah and he's like no no you're gonna
take these bombs
and you're gonna like it yeah basically
but it was like pretty funny but
honestly i laughed my ass off when he
when he snatched that gun away from that
dude and like just got him right there
well because he kind of pushed him over
the hood of the car and his legs kind of
went like that and he just went wham
like right into the [ __ ] dude's
crotch and i was like excellent
that was [ __ ] awesome yeah but yeah i
mean
i had seen this movie
um
probably once or twice
when i was a kid i feel like louie
brought it up earlier that it was on
cable like every weekend i feel like it
was it was always on
not necessarily even the pay channels i
feel like it was on like usa network or
some [ __ ] layer tbs or some [ __ ] like
that i feel like it was just like on a
lot so i think i saw it a couple of
times back then but i
honestly i didn't really remember
hardly anything about it so it was kind
of cool seeing it again like i said i
didn't
i didn't like it as much as the mechanic
but like you mentioned it's too really
kind of completely different
they're both sort of nominally action
movies but
not they're not really the same like not
really not totally the same
so i don't know
but it was still really good though i
enjoyed it a lot
i enjoyed uh
well i kind of liked it because charles
bronson's character was just so
but he didn't make a show of like being
a badass or anything like i said he was
just trying to be a farmer and just
trying to get his [ __ ] crop picked
for the year and that's kind of all he
was worrying about and then like all
these people kept [ __ ] with him and
he was just kind of like bemused about
the whole thing and i found that very
funny you know what i mean yeah uh you
know in some of the lines he said he
just never got rattled or
anything like that
because i think like the when he was in
the uh in the holding tank like with
that other gangster
yeah he's like hey you gonna eat that
sausage and the guy cuz like i said he
has anger issues he could have just
given him the sausage and none of this
movie would have happened but no he had
to push the tray off on the floor like a
[ __ ] toddler and say help yourself
yeah and he's like oh if you know if
you're not gonna eat the sausage like
nobody can have a sausage okay i see it
anymore but he didn't like you know he
didn't say anything mean to him or
anything he was just like oh okay
well that's because he had been in a
vietnamese prison of war camps yeah
there was nothing that could happen to
him that wasn't in jail yeah
he's just like whatever prison that's
prison that's not prison
that's just a place where you sleep yeah
so you know he wasn't even worried about
going to jail
yeah mm-hmm
and yeah it's a good movie though it's a
good movie it's good
i really liked that scene too where uh
you know he stopped at like a
like a convenience store or something
right when he was trying to like make a
deal with the cops after he had
kidnapped the the gangster
and then he didn't have any change so he
asked the girl like the lady that was
running the convenience store yeah
ask it well he's like can i please like
use the phone and blah blah and then um
so she's like yeah that's fine like
because he didn't have 50 cents or
whatever and so he uses the phone a
couple times and he's like hey can i
have a couple beers too and she's like
yeah go on and i was just kind of like
is he seriously like asking for free
[ __ ] but then like later
she he's uh he sent the gangster's
girlfriend back to pay her like three
dollars and 85 cents for her but she
wasn't like oh my god that's awesome
yeah he made her you made her goodbye
and she said what some guy told me to
come by here give me 3.85 cents that's
how much the beers of the phone call he
only told him he told him he was gonna
pay her yeah i thought that was like
[ __ ] funny uh but yeah i just really
really liked his character in this he
was just so he was so unflappable yeah
and i just thought that was like super
funny well that was well that was
charles bronson's thing i guess yeah is
it you know yeah i don't know if i've
ever seen charles bronson like have a
[ __ ] meltdown no he's not a meltdown
type of dude
he just goes silent he's kind of a more
like steely yeah i'm gonna kill your ass
which you're like okay
yeah he's not one of those
no you know kind of although that would
be kind of funny to say i don't know he
was in so many movies i don't know if he
did that definitely you can see that
he's the prototype for uh arnold
schwarzenegger
um
uh
[ __ ] um
dude he played ramp stallone
um
you know he he's he's a
he's a prototype action star
yeah you know a lot of the 80s guys
we're probably we're going to be based
on this
yeah i see it but also steve mcqueen
he's just one of them but he he does
good
he's good tyler says this has to be the
best watermelon movie of all time name a
better watermelon movie it can't be done
there's a scene where they come in there
with uh smith and wesson mk 760s the bad
guys which is kind of a rare submachine
gun
the story behind those guns which kind
of ties into the vietnam the vietnam
theme behind us anyway they got the
whole damn watermelon
uh they got the whole watermelon harvest
in this damn barn and the gangsters
[ __ ]
majestic got away so the only thing the
gankers do is shoot the watermelons with
the submachine guns they just [ __ ]
unload and like just such a petty ass
yeah destroy a lot of the crap that way
the um
for a little bit of gun history the uh
the smith wesson mk 760 was a uh
an american copy of the carl gustav
[ __ ] submachine gun
special forces was using those in
vietnam and uh sweden said no we're not
going to sell any more weapons to the
united states so we had to make our own
and smith and wesson made a good copy of
it called the mk 760.
and
special forces u.s special forces
carried them for a while there's during
a time when u.s advisers were down there
and it was all unofficial they couldn't
carry an american issue
military weapon they had to
they were disguised as civilian
mercenaries is what they were disguised
as so you need an alternate weapon for
that
they still do that today nowadays they
use contractors
but special forces also
impersonates contractors they'll
impersonate foreign troops if they have
to so they just do whatever
they'll impersonate the enemy which is
back in world war two they get you
honked
or hanged
but uh yeah if it's a person it's hanged
yeah that's the only time you ever don't
know i don't know why but i think that's
zach there's some dudes out there that
are hungry
[Laughter]
you know what i mean you know i'm coming
at you sideways like that
you know what i mean
you mean like what i mean when you're
hanging a person like to execute them
that's the only time that you would use
hanged as these
yeah every other time that song i don't
know why i don't know who made up that
role but that's what the rule is uh camp
guy said i noticed the phone booths in
gator i just watched after the podcast
and yes that's the georgia flag and
capitol building in the opening scene
yeah yeah i thought that was georgia
um slasher fred says charles bronson was
also in the western classic once upon a
time in the west yes he was uh dominic
bomb recommends hard times 1975 with
charles bronson which we will probably
get around to
yeah sergio leone originally wanted
charles bronson for the man with no name
trilogy but got clint eastwood in the
end yeah so cam guy how did you like the
gator series did you see uh white
lightning also
white lightning yeah i think it's a good
little series
pookie's laying on her back with her
hands up like that is she really now
she's stretching no okay she's like
she's like i'm being cute and you guys
are missing it you're like
says he's watching it now he must be
watching white lightning now
oh okay yeah yeah yeah they're free on
youtube
yeah i'm like i'm i always forget
because we have so many streaming
services yeah um
you know nowadays like even pay ones we
have netflix we have shutter we have
hulu and amazon prime and then you have
the free ones we have two to be we have
uh peacock who sling and i have all
these different ones and i always forget
that youtube also has free movies that
you can watch all these all these 70s
movies uh and and the early eighty ones
uh 80s one so they aged really well i
liked them uh now
zack was saying that
that it wasn't until the 80s i think he
said this as you could tell how it
wasn't really into the 80s where action
became kind of like a smooth chamber
before that was kind of
kind of uh
kind of crappy looking
70s action was
all practical in-camera effects you know
if you were going to do a stunt somebody
had to actually do it
so the [ __ ] was pretty [ __ ] dangerous
and a lot of times you couldn't get a
hollywood studio to to underwrite that
[ __ ] just because of the risks involved
so it was a lot of times it was smaller
uh independent
uh studios would risk it
and
you know
the end result was actually a lot better
than what the studios were doing most of
the time
and that's where a lot of [ __ ] these
crazy s stuntmen came from especially
the australian ones one out of the mad
max series
some of those dudes were really getting
hurt
some of those accidents that you see in
the mad max series and in you know
especially the first two
they weren't really planned to go down
that way they went a lot worse than
they'd planned but nobody got killed
they used them but some of those dudes
like broke legs and all kinds of [ __ ]
you know although they were serious back
then well yeah and i feel like and i
think a lot of stuntmen have this stunt
people have this is that if you had if
you did a stunt and it went wrong and
you broke a bone or something most of
them would be like oh totally use it
yeah cause you broke a bone for now
because i both yeah i broke a bone for
that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
slow motion captures the [ __ ]
motorcycles [ __ ] just wrapping up and
rolling over guys as they're sliding
across the ground you know i've had that
kind of [ __ ] happen to me in real life
first one nearly killed me it happens
fast
it's just it's like you're looking
through a camera that's spinning or
shaking you you don't you don't really
feel anything it's just it's happening
too fast
so
then when everything slows down you go
oh [ __ ] and you're just numb everywhere
yeah you'll feel it you feel it later
so of course you want to use it print it
did it get it was it good was it good
lay me up in the back of the truck get
me out of here
you know grantham says southern comfort
is free on youtube right now yeah i've
heard about that one uh
i should probably re-watch that i feel
like i saw that as well that's burt
reynolds isn't it
is that burt reynolds wait is he in that
i didn't think he was in that but i
didn't i i don't remember sounds
familiar bee's driving says jenny i sent
you some stuff from mexico today you
will get it on friday well thank you
very much i hope i will look out for
that
so uh that all we have to say is mr
majestic okay so it's tuesday today
right okay so tomorrow is the regular
show
and the show we're gonna do tomorrow i'm
excited about this one we're doing
christopher lee and peter cushing okay
yeah i'm calling it gentlemen of horror
all right
so that should be fun like you're
talking about these guys have [ __ ]
wild backgrounds especially christopher
lee i mean yeah christopher lee i was
reading his wikipedia page and i was
like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like it
almost seems like
peter cushing has more of kind of like a
traditional actor background christopher
lee like james bond sounds like somebody
that you would make up yeah like you
know what i mean like in a like if you
read that in a book you'd be like come
on now but he like really did do all
that [ __ ] it's crazy it's crazy
all right so gotta shut it down all
right so uh we will see you guys
tomorrow evening at 5 p.m eastern
standard time so thanks for hanging out
with us today and we'll see you guys
tomorrow